bonsoir à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne
l'audition d'yves nicolas il est
président de la compagnie nationale des
commissaires aux comptes
il a été entendu cette semaine par à les
sénateurs de la commission d' enquête
sur l'évasion fiscale cette commission
d'enquêté a été créée à l'initiative du
groupe communiste son objectif évaluer
l'ampleur de ce phénomène
selon eric moquer et rapporteur de cette
commission denquête la france perdait en
effet chaque année entre 50 et 80
milliards d'euros de recettes en raison
de l'évasion fiscale alors sans plus
tarder l'audition d'yves nicolas bonne
matinée à tous nous accueillons monsieur
yves nicolas vice président de la
compagnie nationale des commissaires aux
comptes
je vous rappelle monsieur le président
que conformément aux termes de l'article
6 de l'ordonance du 17 novembre 58
relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires votre audition
doit se tenir sous serment et que tout
faux témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles qu'elles soient
34-13 et 400 34-15 du code peine
en conséquence je vais vous demander de
bien vouloir prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité pour
ce faire vous devez la main droite et
dire je le cherche
je vous inviterai je le jure je vous
remercie je vous propose de commencer
cette audition par n'est que exposé
liminaire en fonction de questions qui
vous ont été éventuellement poser et
puis après je passerai la parole aux
rapporteurs de la commission monsieur
bloquer les autres membres brandt mais
d'autres questions éventuelles
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président
bonjour mesdames messieurs la première
chose que peut-être je souhaiterais
c'est que je me présente en effet je
suis vice président de la compagnie
nationale des commissaires aux comptes
je suis aussi président de la compagnie
régionale des commissaires aux comptes
de versailles puisque et physique
absolument puisque nous sommes organisés
à partir des cours d'appel il ya autant
de compagnies régionales que deux cours
d'appel et la compagnie nationale donc
lequel je si vous avez d'accord je vous
expliquerai un début son rôle après
organise la profession autour de ses
caisses régionales de ses compagnies
régionales pardon je suis diplômé de
l'écosphère de commerce de paris
j'exerce la profession de commissaire
aux comptes de ti depuis plus de 30 ans
et j'exerce ce métier de commissaire aux
comptes et non je suis aussi expert
comptable mais je suis plus
particulièrement commissaires aux
comptes et je l'exercent dans un cabinet
assez important à neuilly donc varier
hauts-de-seine qui est membre d'un daim
d'un réseau international et j'en suis
le directeur général pour ce qui est de
la compagnie nationale des commissaires
aux comptes
je voulais vous expliquer un petit peu
quel était son rôle et ce qu'elle
représentait aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui nous avons dix neuf
mille 0,52 commissaires aux comptes
alors je ne sais pas à quelle date
exacte c'est peut-être au 1er juin ou ou
du moins au 1er mai donc 19000 0,52 à
l'intérieur on a deux types de
commissaires aux comptes
on a des personnes physiques et les
personnes morales les personnes
physiques représentent à peu près 73%
des commissaires aux comptes et les
personnes morales 27
nous sommes une profession qui comme
beaucoup d'autres se féminise de plus en
plus puisque aujourd'hui nous avons 18
points 5 % de femmes
on sait peu mais j'ai connu la
profession il y avait très peu de femmes
qui exerçait donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes donc à 80 % des hommes et à 19 %
des femmes
nous exerçons des mandats dans diverses
formes de société puisque c'est la loi
qui définit l'obligation de l'audit
légal et donc l'obligation d'avoir un
commissaire aux comptes
nous exerçons d'abord surtout dans des
sociétés par actions simplifiée les ss
presque à 50% en société anonyme 19,3
pour cent c'est la seule société
juridique où il ya obligation quelle que
soit sa taille d'avoir des commissaires
aux comptes ce qui n'est pas le cas des
autres formes juridiques il ya 8 % de la
crl 11,8 pour cent d'associations et 11%
d'autres types de forme juridique
souvent des des organismes proches de
l'état ou dans des collectivités locales
donc au total ça fait 224 1733 mandat et
vous des biens que à l'intérieur il ya
des toutes petites entreprises comme de
très grandes cotées au cac 40
les effectifs de la profession sont
aussi très répartie
les cabinets qui ont plus de 50 salariés
représentent seulement 15% du total et
les moins de dix salariés donc beaucoup
de professer de professionnels qui
exercent à titre personnel représentent
plus de la moitié de la profession donc
vous voyez qu'on a à la fois des
cabinets qui peuvent avoir jusqu'à 2000
collaborateurs et d'autres qui exercent
seuls nous émettons puisque ça le nôtre
notre travail principal si je puis dire
nous donnons nous certifier les comptes
de ces entités et donc nous émettons
chaque année 224 1733 rapport donc il
faut bien le dire à 97% une
certification pure et simple ça veut
dire que nous n'avons pas d' observation
ni réserve sur ses comptes dans 2% des
cas nous faisons des réserves et dans 0
5% 0.5 ça peut être après 1084 rapport à
l'année dernière nous refusons de
certifier les comptes 1084 sur 224 1733
soit 0 25% à 6 j'avoue ça peut vous
sembler faible mais il faut bien
comprendre qu évidemment avant d'émettre
notre rapport définitif nous expliquant
à l'entreprise qu' il ya des problèmes
dans ses comptes et que nous refusons
les certifier donc dans la majorité des
cas les comptes sont rectifiées par le
conseil d'administration afin d'avoir
une certification des comptes puisque
l'impact de refus de certification peut
être très important pour l'entreprise et
pour son environnement
le commissaire aux comptes existent
depuis longtemps en fait sans eux on le
sait peut-être moins puisque la fonction
de réviseur des comptes a été créée par
la révolution industrielle par la loi
sur les sociétés du 24 juillet 1867
alors progressivement le métier a
beaucoup progressé avec d'abord la
création de la compagnie nationale des
commissaires aux comptes en 1969
et puis deux phases d'évolution
extrêmement importante notre profession
la loi relative aux nouvelles
régulations économiques n è re qui a
unifié le statut du commissaire aux
comptes en 2001 et puis dernièrement la
loi tigres des financières
lsf qui a instauré la séparation des
fonctions d'audit et de conseil et qui a
créé notre instance de supervision la
haute autorité qui s'appelle le le haut
conseil du commissariat aux comptes que
nous dans notre jargon abréviation
appelle le h3c haut conseil du
commissariat aux comptes
la compagnie nationale des commissaires
aux comptes donc constitue l'instance
représentative donc des 15000
commissaire aux comptes en france elle
vise à défendre c'est son objectif
l'intérêt des professionnels auprès des
pouvoirs publics
elle rencontre aux régulateurs et au
ministère de la justice qui bien sûr nos
tutelles elle a un double rôle à la fois
donc d'autorité technique moral et
institutionnel et d'animation durée du
réseau régional dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure
donc les 33 compagnie régionale des
commissaires aux comptes qui dans le
jargon on appelle ça les crcc par
rapport à la cncc qui bien sûr la
compagnie nationale alors notre
organisation est assez simple nous avons
un conseil national qui est l'organe
décisionnaire de la profession qui est
composé de 91 commissaire aux comptes
ce bureau national ce conseil national
donc été représentative de toutes les
compagnies régionales en fonction de
leur importance on les conseillers
régionaux sont élus conseillers
nationaux mon organisation qui peut qui
donc à deux étages les commissaires aux
comptes et lisent les conseillers
régionaux qui eux mêmes
elie certes certains d'entre eux
deviennent conseiller national et font
donc partie de ce conseil national de 91
membres le bureau national qui est
l'organe exécutif est élu par le conseil
national
il se compose de treize membres le
président de la cncc
j'en profite pour dire donc qui
s'appelle claude cazes qui regrette de
pas pouvoir être là aujourd'hui mais bon
je le représente
merci et donc il a trois vice présidents
dont moi même deux représentants du
département des marchés financiers alors
ça aussi c'est une s'était instauré par
la loi de 6 et financière un certain
nombre d'entités dont nous sommes
commissaires aux comptes sont définis de
par la loi est maintenant de aussi au
niveau des directives audit de la
commission européenne de l'union
européenne comme les intérêts des
entités d'intérêt public c'est à dire
qu'un seconde entité qui
sont considérés comme étant encore plus
importante que d'autres en termes de
d'importance économique et parmi celles
ci on a évidemment les sociétés cotées
et ses sociétés cotées donc les
commissaires aux comptes qui ont des
mandats dans les sociétés cotées font
partie d'un département spécifique à
l'intérieur la compagnie nationale qui
s'appelle le département des marchés
financiers
évidemment il est une co tutelle en
dehors du ministère de la justice et du
à choix c'est celui de la m f puisque là
il m'a fait bien sûr et le régulateur de
ces sociétés là alors les missions des
commissaires aux comptes
donc il a bien sûr été précisée par la
loi notamment les articles l lui 122 9
et 8 122 12 du code de commerce
alors si je vais assez vite parce qu'ils
sont assez longs le premier est
évidemment celui que qu'est le plus
connu c'est la certification des comptes
annuels et consolidés
donc c'est une mission légale d'intérêt
général qui consiste à exprimer une
opinion sur la régularité la sincérité
et l'image fidèle des comptes annuels
des sociétés à vérifier aussi la
sincérité la concordance avec les
comptes annuels des informations
financières qui sont fournis l'assemblée
générale puisque en dehors des comptes
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'autres
informations qui sont données à
l'assemblée générale
il a aussi c'est assez original puisque
autant ces deux missions sont souvent
présentes dans les autres pays européens
celui-là est un peu nouveau puisqu'il
est purement français prévenir les
difficultés dans le cadre de la
procédure d' alerte dire que nous avons
nous ne venons pas seulement une fois
par an regarder les comptes des
entreprises nous devons observer ce qui
se passe dans l'entreprise
et lorsque des situations difficiles
apparaissent nous avons une obligation
de procéder à une alerte d'abord au
président auprès du président de conseil
d'administration et puis au bout d'un
certain temps auprès du président du
tribunal de commerce
nous avons aussi
nous effectuons alors ça c'est assez
important aussi à comprendre qu'une
mission d'audit a pour base des
contrôles effectués par sondage sur la
base de l'évaluation bien sûr des
systèmes contre halm de l'environnement
de contrôle interne de l'entreprise et
que donc puisque si la phase sondage
notre opinion est donné à partir d'un
seuil de significativité nous ne pouvons
pas donner une opinion en disant que les
comptes sont juste à l'euro près bien
entendu c'est à en fonction de la taille
de l'entreprise et en fonction de la
significativité d'une erreur sur l'image
fidèle de ses comptes
notre notre mission est aussi bien sûr
de vérifier les informations de nature
comptable et financière qui sont donnés
par l'entreprise on respecte on contrôle
aussi le respect entre les actionnaires
pour que l'égalité entre actionnaires
soient respectés et que donc certains
n'est pas des informations privilégiées
par rapport à d'autres nous devons aussi
communiquer sur des irrégularités
inexactitudes auprès évidemment du
conseil d'administration nous devons
donc je les dis déjà prévenir par la
posture d' alerte si nous sommes dans un
entreprise qui peut avoir des
difficultés rapidement on dirait
pas dans des problématiques de
trésorerie 1
nous avons aussi la loi nous demande
aussi de révéler au procureur de la
république des faits délictueux
je pense qu'on en reparlera sans mettre
au niveau de significativité ou de
contenu à ces faits délictueux donc
c'est un une mission générale et nous
avons aussi bien sur l'obligation de
déclarer tout soupçon de blanchiment de
capitaux et financement du terrorisme
auprès de traction que vous voyez le
panel assez large
alors pour faire tout ce travail là nous
avons des normes d'exercice
professionnel dans notre jargon n est là
beaucoup de jargon je pense que beaucoup
de professions qui font des jargons
cenap donc ce sont les normes dans
laquelle nous devons travailler les
diligences que nous ont respectés
aujourd'hui ces nappes elles sont au
nombre de 44
donc vous voyez que c'est un petit
bouquin de normes 7 6 nov
et ça aussi c'est une particularité
française sont élaborés bien sûr par la
compagnie nationale des commissaires aux
comptes qui les transmet au garde des
sceaux pour homologation après avis du
h3c donc le note l'autre notre haute
autorité de supervision
c'est assez original parce que à côté de
ça il existe des normes d'audit
international qu'on appelle les
internationaux dit standard qui sont
appliquées aux je dirais plus ou moins
dans tous les pays du monde
nous nous devons en plus bien entendu
observer ces normes d'audit mais les
faire homologuer par le garde des sceaux
s'est pas seulement les traduire
c'est aussi les mettre dans un contexte
français ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
d'autres pays européens où on a on
applique directement des normes
internationales qui sont souvent bien
sûr ont élaboré en anglais la valeur des
nappes est importante pour nous parce
qu'elles ont un statut d'arrêté
ministériel donc un caractère public qui
les rend opposable au tiers et incite
une analyse encore plus notre rôle de
normalisateurs alors c'est normal on
quel objectif il ya des normes de
définition de la démarche d'audit des
commissaires aux comptes
comment il doit s'y pendre pour
comprendre l'entreprise son
environnement de contrôle
comment ils organisent ces travaux et il
y a surtout je dirais c'est très
important dans le monde nous vivons un
code d'éthique et de comportement fort
celle qui est assez fort et qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus fort que le
code d'éthique internationale qui existe
au niveau mondial et qui émis par une
institution dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler qui s'appelle l'ifac
l'international federation of
accountants dont la compagnie nationale
bien sûr fait partie et qui sont donc le
rassemblement je dirais de tous
les organisations professionnelles et
comptable à travers le monde voilà je
sais pas si j'ai été un trop long trop
bref mais je réponds que c'est très bien
mais cher président profession oui je
voulais vous mettre en å blême la
procédure de révélations et déclaration
d'accra tel que nous l appliquons ce que
je pense que c'est un sujet qui
événement important pour vous dans votre
commission il faut bien comprendre que
le champ d'intervention du commissaire
aux comptes se limite donc aux missions
qui sont précédemment exposé d'envoyer
nous avons pas une obligation de
résultat d'une obligation de moyens qui
aboutissent donc à à donner une opinion
sur les comptes de l'entreprise
son futur de cette manière par
l'intermédiaire de de la notion de
difficultés quelles poules qu'elle
qu'elle peut rencontrer
cependant en cas de dons nous n'avons
pas une mission active en terme de
matière de fiscalité avons pas
rechercher des problématiques fiscales
ou des erreurs fiscales ou des fraudes
fiscales cependant évidemment au cours
de nos travaux nous pouvons être
confrontés à une situation de fraude
fiscale et donc dans ce cas là le
commissaire en compte deux choses à
faire de déclenchement parallèle la
révélation des faits dit tu auprès du
procureur de la république et la
déclaration à tracfin cas de suspicion
de blanchiment d'argent
nous avons un seul homme de statistiques
aujourd'hui puisque chaque commissaire
aux comptes je ne voulais pas dit fait
chaque année des déclarations d'activité
il doit auprès de la compagnie régionale
à laquelle ils étaient inscrits
et puis vie lancée après consolidé au
niveau de la campagne nationale déclaré
dans ses mandats mais aussi savoir par
exemple s'il a donné une opinion s'il a
fait des réserves mais il dit aussi s'il
a fait des révélations et donc en 2009
nous avions 1075 révélations sur un
total de mandat 223 1388 ce qui fait 0
5% en 2010 et franchement je n'ai pas
d'explication à vous donner
il n'y a eu que 8 186
soit un petit peu moins puisque le
nombre de mandats est quasiment le même
à 2 123 mille cinq cent soixante dix
doigts seulement 0 4%
je pense pas qu'on puisse forcément
tirer le fait que que les sociétés que
nous contrôlions ont été beaucoup plus
attentifs à ces pour l'homme là je pense
que c'est c'est surtout lié au fait que
nous avons été confrontés ou pas à ce
type de fraude fiscale je vous rappelle
aussi que par rapport à l'ensemble des
entreprises qui existent en france nous
ne vérifions les comptes que d'une assez
de minorités en nombre c'est à dire que
certes les grands d'entre eux sur les
grandes entreprises nous intervenons de
façon obligatoire mais plus l'entreprise
est petite plus aller en dessous d'un
certain seuil où il n'ya pas de
commissaire aux comptes
donc nous nous interrogeons donc cette
obligation est bien sûr prévue par le
droit positif français donc ces articles
823 12 es et l 820 7 du code de commerce
le 823 12 donc dit que nous devons à
partir du moment où nous avons constaté
à ce type de problématique de fraude le
signaler à la prochaine assemblée
générale
bon pour tout ce qui est régularité
inexactitudes relevé par le commissaire
aux comptes aux contrôles implique de la
compliquer si l'accomplissement de sa
mission
ce qui fait que tous les actionnaires
sont au courant malheureusement dans
l'entreprise on a constaté des
irrégularités des inaptitudes nous la
révélant bien sûr procure à la public de
façon quasi immédiate dès que nous en
avons connaissance
souvent d'ailleurs l'opération se fait
en deux temps c'est à dire en général il
ya un dialogue oral avec le procureur ou
ses substituts pour lui expliquer le
problématique et puis après on en voit
un écrit qui confirme les faits sachant
que vous doutez bien qu'on est dans une
situation où quelquefois il n'ya pas
complètement certitude puisque nous
voyons des faits qui nous inquiète qui
nous oblige évidemment à faire des
investigations ne peut plus pousser mais
ils n'ont pas vraiment les moyens de la
police ou du procureur pour pour aller
beaucoup plus loin
et pour ce donc ce qui est des
obligations relatives la lutte contre le
blanchiment
bien sûr c'est défini au titre 6 du
livre 5 du code monétaire et financier
alors la définition des faits délictueux
puisque c'est les mots qui sont obtenues
par la loi pour nous ce sont des faits
ou des irrégularités susceptibles de
recevoir des tribunaux une qualification
pénale et sont des faits susceptibles de
présenter un caractère suspect au regard
de la loi pénale donc 70 définition
assez large
donc c'est pour ça que vous disais que
souvent nous avons eu une conversation
orale avec le substitut du procureur
parce que la définition pénale n'est pas
forcément évidente pour nous du fait que
nous n'avons pas tout toute
l'information concernant les
problématiques
alors ce que faisons nous lorsque nous
avons nous seulement affronter une
problématique de ce style bon bien sûr
la base de notre de notre métier c'est
le scepticisme et le jugement
professionnel c'est à dire c'est nous
avons eu un code d'éthique dont j'ai
parlé thaler qui nous pousse à être le
plus indépendant possible vis-à-vis de
l'entreprise donc bien entendu nous
pouvons nous pouvons personnellement
avoir des prêts des emprunts des
contrats d'assurance
nous pouvons avoir des liens personnels
avec avec le chef d'entreprise par
exemple
donc tout ça est bien défini et contrôle
et donc par le haut conseil du
commissariat aux comptes dont je n'ai
pas dit aussi qu'il a un rôle important
de contrôles qualité nous nos cabinets
sont contrôlés par le haut conseil du
commissariat aux comptes
certains chaque année certains tous les
trois ans au tous les six ans être
certain que nous appliquons bien sûr nos
dossiers
ces normes notamment la dépendance les
missions de conseil comme j'ai dit sont
la plupart interdite et le code
d'éthique français d'anthologie français
est certes le plus strict on
s'enorgueillit même à travers le monde
et d'ailleurs ils inspirent peut-être un
tas vous parlez une livre vert qui a été
mis dernièrement par monsieur barnier
commissaire européen pour essayer de
moderniser notre métier au niveau
européen ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
en s'inspirant beaucoup de l'exemple
français
donc nous nous sommes des gens
sceptiques et à partir de là donc
lorsque nous avons des faits que l'on
considère bizarre et bien entendu nous
devons investiguer beaucoup plus mais
nous n'avons pas de recherche active
dire que dans notre programme de travail
ne lisons pas nous recherchons dans la
fraude fiscale nous recherchons des fait
d'études mais évidemment à partie moment
où les opérations les transactions sont
significatives nous les regardons et
donc à travers ça nous pouvons voir ce
nombre de choses je vous ai parlé de
l'âme des modalités de régulation mais
entendu alors bien entendu nous ne
sommes pas nous avons derrière cela une
problématique et bien sûr évidente si
nous nous révélions pas ou si nous
révélions de façon tardive bien sûr que
le commissaire aux comptes pourraient
être poursuivis pénalement
en cas de non révélation en cas de
révélation tardive donc un risque pénal
mais il ya aussi un risque disciplinaire
puisque dans chaque cour d'appel il y
existe une chambre de discipline qui
évidemment pilotés par des magistrats du
ressort pour éventuellement aboutir
avertissements blâmes interdiction
temporaire au bout radiation de la liste
pour les commissaires qui soient des
feuilles évidemment c'est un sujet
important puisque mu qui qui
heureusement pas très courant
alors pour qui la déclaration traque fin
en cas de suspicion ou de blanchiment
d'argent l'a donc j'en ai déjà parlé
c'est donc le l'article 823 12 du code
de commerce
nous avons une norme d'exercice les nets
dont vous ai parlé spécifique qui est
relative aux obligations du commissaire
aux comptes relative la lutte contre le
blanchiment des capitaux et le
financement du terrorisme
ça ça me paraît très important parce
qu'il se montre bien que c'est pas
quelque chose qui est subsidiaire
ça fait partie des normes normale et les
diligences normales du commissaire aux
comptes et qui a été donc homologué par
le garde des sceaux
donc lorsque nous sommes dans une
entreprise nous avons à faire à sa
nombre de choses de façon obligatoire
la première c'est de bien identifier
l'entité canton d'identifier l'entité
évidemment être sûr que finalement elle
est inscrite au registre du commerce
mais aussi quels sont ses actionnaires
quelles sont ses dirigeants sont-ils
français sont-ils étrangers s'ils sont
étrangers quelle est leur leur domicile
leur identité enfin leurs liens avec
d'autres entreprises éventuellement sur
lesquels la société que nous ont dit on
a des liens commerciaux ou juridique
donc on examine donc les opérations qui
sont réalisés par l'entité et on vérifie
la cohérence de ses opérations avec la
connaissance de l'entité bien entendu
tout ce qui est transaction ou opération
exceptionnelle qui n'est pas dans
l'habitude dans le l'objectif l'objet de
la société attire nos regards et fait
aboutir vivement des investigations plus
importante
l'autre chose qui nous est demandé dans
ce nombre d'artistes pro finale qui est
aussi très importance et qui n'est pas
facile nous avons l'obligation aussi de
rechercher le bénéficiaire effectif
notamment d'une transaction
exceptionnelle mais aussi de
l'actionnaire majoritaire de
l'actionnaire qui dirige l'entreprise
vous pouvez voir des cascades de société
qui fait que bon l'actionnaire
majoritaire est une société inscrite
dans un pays étranger qu elle même
détenue par une autre dont vous voyez un
peu là la difficulté laquelle on peut se
trouver et nous devons tout faire pour
obtenir qu'elle est le bénéficiaire
ultime est effectif
la nature des opérations a déclaré à
trac fin évidemment ces opérations qui
porte sur des sommes dont on soupçonne
on a de bonnes raisons de soupçonner
qu'elle provienne d'une infraction
or fraude fiscale passible d'une peine
privative de liberté super un an
ça c'est important ou un participe au
financement du terrorisme on déclare
aussi à trac fin les sommes aux
opérations dont six dont on soupçonne
une bonne raison de soupçonner qu'elle
provienne une fraude fiscale mais
uniquement lorsqu'il est en présence
d'au moins un critère qui est défini par
un décret donc du 16 juillet 2009 fois
donc vous voyez que si je peux résumer
notre notre mission concernant cette
problématique nous avons pour tout ce
qui est des faits délictueux une
obligation de révélation au procureur de
la république de façon urgente alors il
ya une tolérance des parcs est d'à peu
près à moi c'est une purement une
tolérance mais qui a été définie dans
certains parcs et nous avons un mois
pour d'éclairer déclaré des faits
délictueux la raison en est souvent que
il faut un petit peu investiguer pour
aller jusqu'au bout et pouvoir déclarer
au procureur les choses le mieux
possible ce qui est important aussi
c'est qu'au niveau des faits délictueux
n'y a aucun niveau de significativité
ans nous avons a déclaré tout ce que
nous rencontrons
quel que soit le montant que soit
l'importance nous devons même déclaré si
le fait délictueux a été corrigée ou
même si le fait délictueux a été déjà
été déclarées par l'entreprise qui
arrive souvent évident puisque quand on
parle de fait les tueuses c'est ça tort
quand ça concerne aussi malheureusement
les employés d'entreprises et pas que le
chef d'entreprise
donc sur ce sujet là je pense qu'on a
une pratique maintenant assez ancienne
et sur lesquels nous avons un dialogue
assez continue avec les pros kuchar
procureur de chaque ressort sur sur ses
pratiques pour ce qu'ils traquent fin
c'est sûr que c'est d'ailleurs plus
nouveau pour nous puisque c'est arrivé
beaucoup plus après je sais que et sur
les discussions des présentations avec
les responsables de trac fin ils ont une
volonté à ce qu'on a eu beaucoup plus
vite et beaucoup plus rapidement dans
dans des déclarations de soupçon il est
clair que comme c'est pas un objectif
pour nous de chercher ces problématiques
elle tombe je dirais de de façon un
petit peu au hasard et souvent elles
doivent être définies de façon un peu
plus précises parce que voir des sommes
d'argent qui qui qui qui qui font
enlever une transaction ils font que
nous on investigue un peu plus pour
savoir s'ils sont vraiment frauduleuse
inonde on abhorre vraie traque fin de
beaucoup de choses voilà donc pour vous
dire que nous avons donc ces obligations
qui me semble extrêmement importante et
sur lequel nous sensibilisons beaucoup
nos confrères pour les appliquer très
bien merci beaucoup dans ma chair à
porter bien je suis vice président
remercie de votre présentation
donc j'ai bien noté que 97% des rapports
que vous rendiez et émettait nelly
favorable je vais m'intéresser au 0 5%
forcément qui ont donné lieu à un refus
ans intéresse toujours autant qu'ils
arrivent en retard à jamais ceux qui
arrivent à l'heure qui sont le tram
johan majorité a comme vous le savez
mais est-ce que danser 0 5% de rapports
ayant donné lieu à un refus de votre
part enfin de la part des commissaires
aux comptes
est ce que certains étaient liés à des
problèmes de fraude fiscale d'évasion
fiscale et si oui est ce que vous
pourriez illustré de quelques exemples
concrets
franchement très peu lorsqu on émet des
réserves dans les rapports c'est plutôt
des problématiques de certification par
rapport soit à à l'absence d'information
dire que la société ne donne pas les
bonnes informations qu'elle doit donner
à ses actionnaires soit parce que
l'interprétation de principes comptables
ou de méthodes comptables ne sont pas
bonnes ce qui évidemment a un impact
soit sur l'image filtrer les résultats
soient des incertitudes absolues par
exemple une entreprise qui est sur
lequel on a des incertitudes sur
certains actifs
mais au nom des passifs qui pourrait
être absolument monstrueux mais sur
lequel il ya un risque latent et un
gerald ces risques sont qu'un pas
souvent des risques fiscaux alors il
peut arriver quand même que nous
puissions aboutir à des réserves sur des
risques notamment sur les risques
fiscaux parce que nous avons détecté en
effet un risque fiscal latent qui n'a
pas été appréhendé par l'entreprise et
sur la réponse en général du dirigeant
c'est de dire bien vous avez peut-être
raison il ya ce risque mais bon d'abord
et c'est paris c'est absolument je me
défends et j'explique pourquoi et qui
vous savez et et des avocats qui vont
l'aider à convaincre l'administration
fiscale que son point de vue n'est pas
celui-là bon et puis donc ce qui arrive
souvent c'est que l'homme chen reprise
de 10 mais tant qu'il n'est pas avéré il
n'y a pas de raison d'en parler ni deux
le provisionnés dans ces cas là en effet
c'est le jugement professionnel du
commissaire aux comptes qui doit prendre
en compte ce sujet là si je comprends
bien la plupart du temps c
un désaccord sur le provisionnement des
risques oui exactement
en général nos commissaires aux comptes
un disque gare à risque visuellement on
chez d'entreprise cij de provisions je
ne provisionne passer ça absolu vous
avez une vision différente et on peut
avoir une vision différente parce que le
chef d'entreprise à faire appel à son
avocat fiscaliste qui veut lui dire au
moins le risque et 2x et puis nous même
dans nos cabinets nous avons des experts
sur des sujets et on peut avoir une
appréhension un peu différent donc ça
peut aboutir à des écarts d'évaluation
qui s'ils ne sont pas traités peuvent
aboutir à des réserves à un refus de
certification il faudrait vraiment que
ça soit gigantesque mais plutôt à des
réserves dans nos rapports
est ce que l'administration fiscale vous
collaborez avec vous pour édicter des
normes du point de vue de de ces sujets
dans
non enfin il faut bien comprendre aussi
que nous sommes commissaires aux comptes
donc ne sommes pas l'expert-comptable
d'entreprise
par contre l'expert comptable de
l'entreprise lui et un conseil de
l'entreprise et c'est à lui a conseillé
son chef dans le chef d'entreprise sur
l'orangé mois pour compléter le vous
avez les deux métiers c'est à dire dans
une entreprise vous êtes parfois
commissaires aux comptes et et dans
l'entreprise voisine vous êtes à la fois
expert comptable donc vous avez la même
connaissance
c'est exact c'est exact que la plupart
des commissaires aux comptes sont
experts comptables le même diplôme le
code déontologie est extrêmement stricte
évidemment on ne peut pas être à la fois
expert comptable et commissaire aux
comptes dans la même entreprise mais les
deux les deux métiers sont complètement
différents autant l'expert comptable est
là pour assister le chef d'entreprise
le conseiller et lui dire comment
traiter un problématiques fiscales
autant nous n'avons absolument rien lire
seulement à juger si le traitement est
adéquat ou pas mais ce qui veut dire
donc forcément nous avons une certaine
connaissance du sujet puisque nous avons
pu le pratiquer dans une entreprise
concurrente ou alors vous avez évoqué
l'existence d'un espèce de chartes d'un
code éthique l'un d'eux de normes de
principe qui guide votre action
apparemment plus sévères en france que
dans le reste de l'europe
c'est ça vous indiquez mais reste posée
néanmoins inévitable
inévitablement la question de
l'indépendance des commissaires aux
comptes sans mettre en doute l'intégrité
le seuil du travail mais de fait le
faite vous êtes rémunéré par vos clients
dans cette fête ça crée une dépendance
et qu'est-ce qui peut garantir que donc
vous avez dit le plus que vous soyez le
plus indépendant possible ce qui laisse
quand même une marge ce sain c'est comme
une vraie question qui se pose et on a
eu écho dans la chronique quelques temps
de licenciement d'auditeurs c'est ça
s'est produit j'ai pas d'exemple en tête
mais je sais que ça s'est produit
et pouvez vous indiquer quelle quelle
mesure etc à disposition
surmonter cette difficulté de
l'indépendance totale absolue du
connaisseur par rapport à l'entreprise
qui le dit c'est peut-être une erreur de
langage vous à dire que nous étions
indépendants le plus possible nous
sommes indépendants
il n'y a pas de sujet là dessus et s'est
vérifiée par la terre du contrôle de
qualité dont je vous ai parlé et par
l'intermédiaire du haut conseil du
commissariat qui complètement
indépendant de la profession puisqu'il
est il est dirigé par des magistrats qui
ne sont pas évidents commissaire aux
comptes bon je crois qu'il faut d'abord
dire que nous sommes nommés pour six ans
donc ça veut dire évidemment que même
s'ils sont payés par l'entreprise ne
sommes nous sommes nous avons une
mission qui est donnée par l'assemblée
générale pour six années dont les
honoraires sont définis en général dès
le départ et la plupart du temps par un
processus d'appel d'offres donc ils se
sont absolument transparente
nous avons beaucoup de mesures pour
garantir cette indépendance
nous avons d'abord par la rotation des
signataires c'est à dire que même si
nous sommes heureux renouvelé pour six
années de plus ça ne sera pas le même
associés signataires pour toutes les
sociétés d'intérêt public donc ça veut
dire que ça notre associé du cabinet qui
va être indépendant et qui va
éventuellement subir les foudres d'un
risque pénal d'un risque civile d'un
risque réglementaire ou d'un risque
disciplinaire puisque nous sommes une
profession qui aime on n'aime pas trop
parler de ça mais c'est quand même la
vérité
nous nous sommes très surveillé par donc
notre totor autre autorité par les
magistrats et nous cumulons les risques
puisque en tant que signataire à titre
personnel ou à titre au nom d'une
personne morale nous
nous avons à nous avons à faire face à
d'éventuelles poursuites pénales civiles
en réparation réglementaire pour ce qui
est par exemple de la m f si tu me
souhaiter côté et disciplinaires donc
nous sommes je dirais très encadré bien
et le fait par exemple de certifier les
comptes d'une entreprise dont un
dirigeant sera un parent le fait
d'accepter un prêt d'une entreprise dans
ton et commissaire aux comptes ça c'est
absolument interdit et c'est la
meilleure façon pour être radié de façon
définitive
donc je veux bien exergue le fait que
nous sommes une des professions
libérales les plus réglementées et les
plus contrôlées qu'ils soient bien alors
en dehors de ça vous savez qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres mesures qui existent
dans ce la profession de commissaire aux
comptes à partir moment vous êtes dans
un groupe de sociétés qu'il ya des
comptes consolidés en france et on est
le seul pays au monde où ça existe nous
avons le co-commissaire aux comptes
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya deux commissaires
aux comptes qui signe le même rapport
imagine un kit août à foot à coup veille
se laisser entraîner vers des faveurs
l'autre évidemment est là pour
l'empêcher ou voit remettre un rapport
qui serait différent du sien lorsque la
la visibilité du problème serait
imminente
donc
je ne vous dis pas que tout est parfait
dans le parfum des mondes parce qu'il ya
toujours des complications mais je pense
que nous avons du fait de ces
réglementations et notamment de la loi
sur des financières n'ont pas parlé tout
à l'heure qui est venu suite au scandale
américain dont vous vous rappelez
certainement avec enron worldcom nous
avons une profession qui est très très
encadré et très surveillé de quels
outils efficaces disposez-vous pour
détecter les anomalies que vous
annonciez tout à l'heure notamment dans
les prix de transfert par exemple ou
l'utilisation de montage et de refuge
fiscaux opaque avec vos accès à
l'ensemble des documents d'une
entreprise donnée sur ce sujet voilà
quels sont vos moyens d'investigation
s'est alors portée à vous poser les
bonnes questions
oui parce que tout dépend du contexte
entreprises lorsque tu une entreprise
française avec des actionnaires français
les choses peuvent être assez simple
puisque bien sûr le commissaire aux
comptes a à droit d'obtenir toutes les
informations qui demandent mais qui
souhaitent
sinon après ce serait un ca serait
considérée comme un obstacle à sa
mission et danse il pourrait d'ailleurs
allé voir le procureur public pour pour
dénoncer cette situation donc pour ce
qui fut une soute et français je dirais
il a tout les moyens pour investiguer
savoir connaître et je pense que sur ce
sujet là il a pas beaucoup de
problématiques sauf si évidemment il a
face à face à lui un des chefs
d'entreprise qui il voudrait lieux
cachés
il a notamment une l'outil en dehors de
l'investigation personnel qui peut faire
avec des spécialistes soit son cabinet
soit qui peut prendre sous traitance
parce que notamment pour ce qui est
d'aider des risques fiscaux ou alors des
manipulations informatiques
tout dépend de la taille du cabinet mais
les cabinets significatifs ont
évidemment ces spécialistes à
l'intérieur leur cabinet et évidemment
il y à des contrôles sur les procédures
informatiques ou sur les déclarations
fiscales qui sont faites les plus petits
peuvent absolument demander un
sous-traitant de les aider sur un poids
ou sur un autre
la complexité mon avis vient lorsque
vous allez dans une filiale d'un groupe
étranger
où la problématique des prix de
transfert par exemple dont vous parliez
n'est pas évidente puisque les gérer au
niveau du siège et dans ce cas là
évidemment le commissaire aux comptes
français peut demander à ce nombre
d'informations mais peut ne pas les
obtenir et peut ne même pas savoir ce
qui se passe au niveau du siège qui est
à l'étranger
donc je pense que le sujet dans le plus
difficile pour nous c'est lorsque nous
sommes commissaire au compte d'une
filiale d'un groupe dans laquelle nous
avons pas des liens directs avec le
groupe et quelquefois même le conseil
d'administration de la société française
lien on trouve beaucoup de personnes
étrangères qui sont pas domicile vous
voyez la difficulté d'obtenir plus
d'informations alors si le groupe est
sérieux
la plupart des groupes étrangers ceux
qui travaillent en france au calme
sérieux
en général le l'auditeur
et l'auditeur de la société mère donc
qui a donc une vision globale sur le
groupe et qui doit dans son dans ses
normes de travail international puisque
l'heure est à l'étranger
regardez les problématiques de prix de
transfert à une communication vis-à-vis
du commissaire aux comptes en france
puisque si la société est consolidée il
doit demander pour donner une opinion
sur les comptes consolidés ensemble
d'informations au commissaire aux
comptes français donc ça va dans ce sens
là mais bien sûr le commissaire français
peut demander aussi un nombre
d'informations à son confrère étranger
qui qui contrôle le groupe
les choses sont plus faciles si le
commissaire aux comptes français manque
du même réseau international donc vous
savez que notre profession pour auditer
les groupes français mais aussi pour
auditer les filiales de groupes
étrangers
c'est de plus en plus organisés en
réseau c'est à dire que chaque chaque
commissaire aux comptes et bien sûr
indépendant localement mais fait partie
d'un réseau international qui permet
justement cette meilleure communication
puisqu'on a des méthodes travail comme
une des demandes d'informations et des
retours d'information est ce que c'était
que vous soyez favorable généralisation
du reporting pays par pays
c'est un peu dans l'air du temps on en
parle est-ce que ça devrait pas répondre
à cette préoccupation et cette
difficulté que vous avez dans votre
action sur les grands groupes
j'apprécie ça parce que ce matin à cette
question était posée un représentant
d'une grande entreprise française qui
trouvait qu'elle est trop loin et est
une hérésie
qu'en pensez vous il fait des preuves de
faisabilité mais ça je ne suis pas assez
pertinent pour pour répondre mais du
fait que les transactions sont de plus
en plus imbriquées entre dans un groupe
entre différentes filiales il est
certain qu'à un certain moment la vision
fiscale groupe est telle que la
transformer en une vision pays par pays
me paraît compliqué maintenant pour ce
qui est des commissaires aux comptes
français évidemment lui même si on peut
lui donner
je parlais des informations sur
pertinentes sur l'impact décisions
fiscales l'étranger
sur sur le transaction française
pourrait être intéressante
je crois plus à ce que je vous disais
avant la la le fait que le que
l'auditeur du réseau l'auditeur pardon
du de la maison-mère communique mieux
avec l'auditeur de ses filiales à propos
des signalements traque fin ou procureur
de la république est ce que vous auriez
un bilan chiffré est qualitatif de
commandes est prévu de l'application de
ce dispositif dans le domaine de la
fraude fiscale plus spécifiquement non
puisque fait sûrs pour les révélations
défectueux on n'a pas le détail je ne
prends pas sur la fraude fiscale
on ajuste les chiffres dont j'ai donné
qu'ils sont globaux donc à l'intérieur
je ne peux pas vous dire quels sont les
faits liés de la fraude fiscale est
possible traque fins et c'est la même
chose que les informations pour
mouvement global vous avez évoqué la
responsabilité des commissaires aux
comptes
en cas de non signalement d'une
situation douteuse bizarre je reprends
vos termes mais en cas de redressement
fiscal de l'entreprise est ce que cette
dont un commissaire a certifié des
comptes est ce que sa responsabilité
de la même manière peut être engagée le
commissaire aux comptes la violence
qu'il le dit à chaque fois une
obligation de moyens mais pas de
résultats
donc je pense que sa responsable de
pointe engagée si on pourrait prouver
que dans ses exigences
c'est des gens étaient insuffisantes et
qu'il n'a pas fait son le travail de
qualité qu'ils le devraient faire et
qu'il aurait permis de voir ce type de
problématique
maintenant comme je vous l'aï dit nous
donnons une flore de travaux et par
sondage
et nous donnons une opinion à partir de
ce seuil de significativité donc tout
dépend du niveau de cette fraude fiscale
si elle est vraiment monumentale et qu'
elle était assez visible là je pense
qu'on pourrait enfin les tribunaux
pourraient soulever le problématique de
sa responsabilité
visible c'est parfois le cas mais on
peut imaginer aussi qu'il y ait
justement des territoires opaques des
dispositifs opaque je pense aux trusts
ou des prête-noms et c'est quand vous
êtes confond avez vous déjà été
confronté à ce genre de situation et si
c'est le cas comment procéder ou dans ce
cas là pour investiguer poursuivre votre
travail
moi personnellement non mais ce que je
voudrais dire aussi c'est que ceux qui
ont l'objectif ces objectifs là en
général choisissent personnalité
juridique en france il n'y a pas de
commissaire aux comptes
puisqu'une très possible de choisir une
entreprise support juridique qui ne
réclament pas un commissaire aux comptes
pourquoi choisir un support juridique
vous savez qu'il ya quelqu'un qui va
vous contrôlez et j'ai en tête
la plus grande banque française et même
européenne qui dispose d'entités dans
des paradis fiscaux et dans ce cas
comment peut-on accéder d'une part à
toutes les informations tous les
documents et de la certifier les comptes
de cet établissement bancaire qui est
dit dans ce dissimule certains actifs au
moins pas vraiment vous répondre je ne
connais pas le dossier
quand vous parlez je pense que tout en
terme général je dire à partir du moment
où vous êtes auditeurs comme ici
rencontre d'un groupe français et que
vous regardez évidemment le les
différentes filiales si vous en voyez
dans des paradis fiscaux
évidemment vous investissez vous
regardez ce qui se passe c'est pourquoi
elles existent quel est leur objectif
maintenant après faut-il encore comme je
vous ai dit alors qu'elles soient
significatives parce qu'il peut y avoir
des tout petits fiel dans certains
paradis fiscaux qui ne sont pas
construits des dons qui sont pas dans le
périmètre de consolidation et sur lequel
donc le commissaire aux comptes
n'intervient pas forcément est-ce qu'il
allait commissaire aux comptes par
exemple je pense aux îles vierges
britanniques et vous connaissance de
cela il ya des auditeurs localement oui
oui aux mêmes règles que soumis aux
règles locales
par contre ne sais pas comment mais je
ne sais pas exactement quelles sont les
règles locales et des îles vierges
britanniques
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que les
les auditeurs lot fours qui sont membres
de réseaux internationaux ont une
obligation de respecter les normes
d'audit international dont je parlais
les et s
supino président une question dans laxe
dans la poursuite de celle qu'ils aient
été posées par notre rapporteur
lorsque des écritures comptables
traduisent un montage juridique à à haut
risque qui peut organiser une
optimisation fiscale qui va de
l'optimisation fiscale à peu près
certaine au plan de la régularité jury à
un peu plus loin la taille normale de
gestion un peu plus loin la butte droit
et un peu plus loin la fraude
quand vous n'êtes pas ça a slave ces
écritures comptables qui sont en face à
ce mécanisme alors vous avez dit tout à
l'heure on investigue bon imaginons que
vous n'arriviez pas à vous extraire de
votre impression le fait qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est un petit peu
agaçant certains vous dirai ce que vous
ouvrez le parapluie dont en termes plus
juridique est ce que vous faites un
signalement automatiquement ou est-ce
que vous inviter à la correction du
système du montage apparemment la
présentation c'est que nous ne vont pas
nous immiscer dans la gestion donc
souvent des montages sont fait parce que
la direction de la société le souhaitent
n'auront pas à donner un avis si c'est
bien ou c'est mal par contre en effet
lorsqu'à démontage un petit peu
compliqué c'est notre devoir surtout
s'ils sont significatifs de regarder si
ces montages n'aboutissent pas en effet
des risques notamment des risques
fiscaux
après c'est une question de jugement
professionnel de savoir si ce risque est
avéré absolue et on a franchi une ligne
jaune et dans ce cas il faut la voir le
procureur public ou si c'est elle ne
l'est pas donc c'est toujours un peu un
cas d'espèce c'est difficile de vous
dire oui ou non
c'est un jugement professionnel en
fonction d'une situation et et en
fonction de sa engins le commissaire aux
comptes consulte alors ils consultent
soient ses associés s'ils sont plusieurs
dans le cabinet soit mais ça m'est
arrivé il consulte le président de sa
compagnie régionale pour comprendre s'il
a bien compris si un vrai sujet alors
après ce qui se passe c'est que en
général et nous les commissaires aux
comptes sont des gens raisonnables ce
qui veut dire qu'à partir du moment où
il ya vraiment un doute
la plupart du temps il
comme je vous dis et à l'heure et
consultant prix consulte il
il appelle le broker la république pour
lui exposer la problématique
les procureurs gens l'acceptent dans un
premier temps que ce soit sans donner de
noms mais pour donner un avis et puis
évidemment lorsque la vie' bon il ya un
gros problème ça aboutit à un écrit avec
évidemment une dénonciation deuxième et
dernier point qui est un peu différent
les rapports lorsque vous les avez
déposé qui peut y accéder
les rapports sur des commissaires aux
comptes
ils se sont ils sont enregistrés du
tribunal de commerce
donc tout le monde puis accéder donc
l'administration peut y accéder sur les
endroits chauds munication absolument ah
oui on l'admet ce qu elle le fait
souvent
est-ce qu'elles exercent souvent son
droit de communication
franchement j'ai peur de vous dire que
c'est pas très souvent parce que je
cherche un exemple et je ne trouve pas
mais elle peut le faire elle même sans
parler sans me demander aux commissaires
aux comptes donc là il faudrait plutôt
demander ça au greffier ou monsieur
vaughan ah non pas du fait que je trouve
que c'est une excellente question
parce qu'elle voulait nous prenons la
bonne réponse mais vraiment vous de
savoir si l'administration fiscale va un
peu plus loin que non sur
l'homogénéisation homogénéisation pardon
sur le territoire européen
mais qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
pays qui avaient plus de difficultés que
d'autres
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer
quel pays en particulier ce qu'il ya un
lien spécifique par rapport à la gestion
supposé bonnes ou mauvaises de ce pays
ensuite
donc vous n'avez pas connaissance du
nombre de faits délictueux ou soumis au
procureur de la république
s'agissant de fraude fiscale ou l europe
rétracte fin vous n'avez pas
connaissance nous puis éventuellement du
montant éventuel que cela pourrait
représenter du tout s'est compliqué ses
divisions
d'accord ce qu'on essaie de chercher
c'est l'efficacité par rapport à la
fraude fiscale quoi l'argent comptant en
vous écoutant en entendant que c'est
assez compliqué c'est difficile pour
vous alors soit parce que vous n'avez
pas les les moyens pour agir
véritablement ils sont insuffisants vous
avez un objectif de deux moyens mais
vous n'avez pas d'objectif de résultat
est ce que d'aller vers un objectif de
résultat sur une solution parmi d'autres
pour une meilleure efficacité est ce que
ça suppose beaucoup plus de moyens pour
les commissaires aux comptes
voilà non mais c'est intéressant qu'on
puisse le savoir pardonnez moi c'est
peut-être une question de béotien mais
j'essaie de voir comment
l'utilisation des commissaires aux
comptes d'être optimum pour aider notre
problématique de la fraude fiscale la
première qu'il première partie votre
question sur l'homologation européenne
c'est un énorme chantier qui est loin
d'être atteint moi ce que j'en ai parlé
c'est pas tellement sur des
problématiques de fraude fiscale ou
c'est plutôt une problématique liée au
statut de l'auditeur ou du commissaire
aux comptes qui est très différent d'un
pays à l'autre et sur lequel les normes
de travail qui comme je vous dis chez
nous seront homologués par le garde des
sceaux donc après avis du h3c donc vous
voyez que c'est beaucoup de gens
extérieurs ils se pensent la façon dont
travaille nous sommes le seul pays
européen qui dans ces procès cela
c'est-à-dire ailleurs c'est le
commissaire aux comptes lui même ou son
institution qui définissait dans le
travail pour ce qui est aussi de la
dépendance du commissaire aux comptes
nos obligations notre côté anthologie
est beaucoup plus sévère par exemple
sans aller très loin que celui qui est
un qui est en place à londres ou à
berlin aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs un
des sujets de la commission européenne
et de cet objectif de réformer notre
métier pour le rendre plus homogène et
il a tendance et nous mais plutôt une
tendance à l'homogénéité dans le sens
d'aller plus proche de notre situation
française pour les autres pays pour ce
qui est de je rappelle que notre mission
n'est pas la recherche de la fraude
fiscale notre mission c'est de donner
une opinion sur des comptes vient aussi
ses comptes sont entachées par des
risques fiscaux importants
ça nous intéresse parce qu'on peut sinon
on est en donne une opinion par rapport
à des risques fiscaux mais il peut y
avoir aussi des risques environnementaux
plein d'autres risques dans l'entreprise
qui ont besoin d'être provisionné au
clan besoin d'être solutionnés donc nous
sommes des gens qui par rapport au
travail que nous faisons
évaluant les risques de l'entreprise et
à partir de là regardons si ces risques
sont réels sont son existe déjà et si
s'ils existent déjà si les provisions
pour permettre de subvenir à ces
problèmes sont passés voilà mes
mais tant que je dirais que le risque
n'est pas vu ou n'est pas soupçonné ou
non on considère qu'il n'est pas avéré
on a on n'a pas le prendre en compte
d'intervenir à nouveau mais est ce que
dans d'autres pays les commissaires aux
comptes rade ont un rôle particulier par
rapport à la fois lors du tout ça aussi
j'étais passé dit absolument la
révélation au coeur la république nous
sommes un des seuls pays au monde où ça
existe dans les autres pays
d'ailleurs le métier d'éditeur n'est pas
du tout le même que nous sépare légal
c'est un le contractuel dans la plupart
des pays anglo saxons l'auditeur est
nommé par un an et est nommé par le
management même pas par l'assemblée
générale
donc il est là il a une lettre de
mission qui est acceptée par
l'entreprise de faire un salon de
travail qui aboutissent à une opinion
c'est pas du tout le népal tour de
contexte enfin dernière question lorsque
vous constatez dans une entreprise dans
les mouvements de trésorerie des
mouvements d'argent liquide de très
important ce qui est le plus part du
temps n'ont rien à voir avec le
fonctionnement de l'économie
fonctionnement de l'entreprise
qu'est ce qui se passe concrètement sur
moi quel est votre rôle et qu'est ce que
vous faites
explications par rapport aux comptables
directeur financier ou directeur général
à face à des vandales et les clés pour
comprendre ce qui se passe et puis
essayer de demande auprès de tiers pour
confirmer ces mouvements les
explications notamment évidemment par
rapport aux banquiers puisque c'est les
transferts d'argent ainsi de suite lui a
priori à une connaissance particulière
recherche des pièces justificatives
compréhension de la réalité de la
transaction bon je pense que à partir du
moment où on a on a ce type de risques
ces types de vue un problème je crois
que nous allons jusqu'au bout ça c'est
mais il faut bien comprendre aussi que
dans certaines notamment grandes
entreprises les transactions tous les
jours c'est des milliers de transactions
donc été difficile de tout les vérifier
donc votre question est dire si vous
avez une obligation de résultat je peux
vous dire que pour certaines entreprises
il faudrait me multiplié nos horaires
par 10 ou par vint donc je pense ça
serait complètement surréaliste
oui le secteur bancaire a été bien sûr
particulièrement chahuté ces dernières
années et la crise financière et au plus
fort de la crise financière notamment
est ce que pour certaines banques
certains établissements de ce type des
commissaires aux comptes avait été amené
à formuler des remarques des réserves
sur l'activité de l'établissement
en amont de ce que la crise a pu révéler
oui parce que vous avez le rapport sur
les comptes
celui que on a beaucoup parlé qui
étaient visibles qui devait l'assemblée
générale mais derrière ça notamment pour
ses établissements financiers qui sont
importants il ya beaucoup d'autres
rapports qui sont émis et discuter avec
que la direction de l'entreprise et avec
les comités d'audit et dans ses rapports
là évidemment on fait l'état de des
diligences qui ont été effectués par le
commissaire au compte des risques qu'il
a vu des problématiques il a rencontré
des solutions qu'il faudra apporter il
ya des recommandations
parce que si on peut pas donner de
conseils on peut faire des
recommandations en disant tel telles
problématiques comptables est traité
comme ça nous pensons qu'elle devait
traiter différemment
donc si si si vous allez dans une banque
et que vous regarde vous demandiez tous
les rapports émis par les commissaires
aux comptes et pas seulement le rapport
sur les comptes
on verrait que ça fait beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses et à l'intérieur
évidemment vous allez trouver mais mon
fait je ne veux pas en parler de façon
précise puisque vous n'êtes pas
forcément des haussiers sûrement des
points d'attention des points de sujets
à traiter qui est qui mettait en exergue
le fait que bon bah des risques existé
et que peut-être un jour il apparaîtrait
de façon plus visible
mais ça vous rentrez dans un sujet qui
est aussi passionnant c'est le rôle de
préventif du commissaire jusque
aujourd'hui le rôle que nous demandons
c'est de donner une opinion sur les
comptes du passé qui ont été déjà été
arrêtés par contre je pense que ça sera
intéressant mais là c'est un débat un
peu plus générale 1,2 de donner aussi un
rôle un peu plus préventif au
commissaire aux comptes comme on l'a on
l'a vu pour le lorsque l'entreprise est
en difficulté parce qu'évidemment
connaissant bien l'entreprise ses
rouages en général connaissant bien
l'activité il est à même d'avoir une
opinion sur sur l'état de ses risques et
l'éventualité que ces risques se réalise
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs que je reviens
parce que c'est beaucoup d'actualité
dans notre profession de ce livre vert
de mme de monsieur michel barnier le
démarrage a été ça c'est à dire il ya eu
cette crise bancaire
qu'ont fait les communes qu'on fait les
auditeurs ont eu lui les problèmes et ne
faut-il pas que les émissions plus
élargie super tu es un rôle un rôle
passionnant ce week-end ne sont prêts à
discuter je déborde au sujet de notre
commission va pas te fais mais justement
ce rôle élargi et qu'est ce que ça
pourrait qu est ce qu on pourrait y
inclure l'élargissement tour e garantir
qu'elle avait une situation de se
retrouver ce lieu a été discutée mais je
dirais pour le moment aérien de 2,2
d'établi du fait que hâter partir du
moment où le commissaire aux comptes et
un tiers indépendant qui a une vision
sur les risques de l'entreprise ne
pourrait-il pas faire un rapport sur ces
risques dire cette entreprise ces
comptes sont sabordés certifié mais elle
encourt sept ans de risques alors
environnementale des risques liés à son
activité
parce que l étant un métier difficile ou
qui en plein retournement des risques
liés à son organisation interne à son
informatique qui peut peut-être qui
n'est pas efficiente
voilà et bien sûr ça peut être des
risques fiscaux vous des risques
juridiques des risques au pacte ul
malheureusement comme un chef
d'entreprise on est entouré de risques
victoire
dans votre activité les nombreux
dossiers que vous avez eu à traiter
est ce que vous avez eu à constater la
délocalisation de d'actifs immatériels
je pense à la gestion des brevets par
exemple dans des territoires un fisc a
été privilégié permut par exemple est-ce
que vous avez été confronté à ce genre
de situation moi personnellement non
mais mais bon par contre des entreprises
qui délocalisent qui ferme une usine
pour fabriquer en loi mais comme j'ai
dit au début nous les missions pas
d'ingestion
nous vérifions que si elles le font
elles respectent les lois et règlements
de la république française concernant
les prix de transfert sur lesquels je
reviens est-ce que vous l'ayez qui sont
dans les grandes entreprises
est ce qui vous semble correctement
contrôlés écoutez pour ce que je mon
expérience personnelle notamment
vis-à-vis de groupes français je vous
dirais oui et de mieux en mieux
d'abord parce que en général ses goûts
français se sont outillés de
spécialistes mis en place des procédures
et puis ils disent ils se savent très
bien surveillé par l'administration
fiscale donc c'est quand même un sujet
assez systématique une dernière question
pèse sur le projet au niveau de l'europe
aussi de mettre en place une assiette
commune laxistes je vais vous en avez
entendu parler bon denman et voilà quel
est votre avis là-dessus auriez-vous les
propositions à formuler éventuellement à
ce sujet comment ça vous fait réagir
je dirais tout ce qui peut aboutir à
plus de clarté au niveau européen me
semble une bonne chose et donc le fait
de d'avoir une assiette fiscale
européenne ne pensa
un très bon sujet maintenant je pense
que pas dominant pas de pignons précises
sur comment il faudrait faire je pense
que ça il faudrait je pense que ça va
dans le bon sens dans le bon sens de
clarification et transparence il n'y a
pas eu de proposition faite non mais je
vois par les commissaires aux comptes
oui au moins une question très simple un
commissaire aux comptes peut-il at il
les moyens de détecter une faute fiscal
dans la mesure où celui ci vérifie la
sincérité et des comptes de l'entreprise
et et at il les moyens d'analyser à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise
le fonctionnement de l'entreprise des
faits des faits qui auraient ce que je
dis pas qu'ils sont en vie qu'aurait pu
être délicat
comme j'ai dit il il a une mission qui
était une mission de vérification des
comptes à travers ça ils vous voient
démontage des opérations sur lequel
évidemment il doit se poser la question
de l'impact fiscal puisque on nous dit
le résultat net après fiscalité donc
vous dire après est-ce qu'il a les
moyens de tout vérifier de tout voir
bien sûr que non il n'a pas les moyens
parce qu'il ya une obligation comme dire
de moyens justement et pas de résultats
maintenant après six essais compétences
dont vous vouliez parler
le commissaire aux comptes avait
apparaît sens des compétences fiscales
le style si c'est que si c'est devenu un
point extrêmement complexe il peut à
faire appel à des spécialistes soit son
cabinet soit extérieur pour demander une
opinion sur un point précis qui sous
lequel il a un souci
je suis sur le livre les propositions de
monsieur banny emballe d'harmonisation
européenne
mais en réalité va falloir convaincre
nos partenaires
en réalité si je comprends bien ça peut
se retourner contre votre profession
c'est à dire si l'harmonisation se fait
a minima je donne un exemple parce que
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure je
crois qu'on est je crois que si j'ai
bien compris vous avez dit on est l'un
des seuls pays où il ya deux
commissaires aux comptes en fonction de
l'année certains de nombreux mégots de
deux critères en termes de chiffre
d'affaires dans les conduits selon ce
décompte
combien de comptes consolidés les
comptes cause des groupes il faut deux
commissaires aux comptes
par exemple une harmonisation à
l'européenne pour le faire revenir en
arrière par exemple revenir à un seul
comme il se rend compte alors par
exemple vous avez raison j'ai vraiment
vigilant parce qu'on est fous nous
sommes le pays en l'occurrence le plus
intransigeant sur la demande de la norme
ou dessous du contrôle et pour autant
n'a pas convaincu donc parfaitement
monsieur le président nous sommes très
attentifs à ce que en effet
l'homogénéisation se fasse entre
guillemets par le bas et qu elle
supprime des règles au niveau européen
que nous appliquons déjà en france bon
pour ce qui est du co commissaire aux
comptes ou du job dit puisque c'est le
terme internationale heureusement la
commission européenne a prévu la
possibilité en option donc ça reste
possible en france a priori on gardera
nos règles spécifiques mais ce qui
serait bien c'est que dans un contexte
de compétitivité pour nos entreprises au
moins vis-à-vis de nos grands voisins
j'irai cette harmonisation se fasse plus
tôt dans notre chance mais encore
faut-il convaincre que de l'efficacité
de notre système
je suis tout à fait d'accord j'ai quand
même compris puis paf est perçu dans
votre audition
deuxièmement je voudrais avoir une
ambiance puisque c'est ce qu'il nous
intéresse nos membres de la commission
sur long sur l'évasion alors sur
l'évasion il ya la fraude et
l'optimisation je dirais est-ce que vous
avez un sentiment qui s'est répandue au
cours des dernières années dans les
grandes entreprises françaises ou en
réalité c'est pas une préoccupation
en réalité il n'ya pas de vraie pression
ou de vraies problématiques pour les
dirigeants des entreprises françaises de
savoir si on doit s'orienter vers une
stratégie fiscale on a parlé de
stratégie fiscale par exemple ce matin
est ce que c'est un sentiment qui veut
se développe tout simplement parce que
je dirais les entreprises même de taille
moyenne sont de mieux en mieux informés
de la compétition fiscale ou au
contraire c'est une stabilité dans votre
profession vous avez pas que c'est le
sentiment que c'est un problème très
particulier qui l'a toujours été
existe en cours des années il y en a
toujours qui ont tendance à franchir la
ligne jaune mais c'est pas le plus grand
nombre ou au contraire c'est une
pression qui est devient de plus en plus
fortes en termes de compétitivité non
moment sentiment c'est plutôt la
deuxième partie de votre propos c'est
que l'optimisation fiscale a toujours
été un souci permanent des entreprises
et donc elle le demeure mais je ne vois
pas de raison de penser que c'est plus
un souci que d'autres sans souci parmi
d'autres et je pense que d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'entreprises ont déjà réfléchi
à ces problématiques depuis longtemps
ils ont mis en place donc donc ya pas je
n'ai pas trahi l'inquiétude participent
à une inquiétude particulière pour nous
plus que d'habitude sur wii de deux
petites questions le cepeo avait rendu
un rapport à il ya quelques années et
mettant en évidence le fait que le les
entreprises des grands groupes du cac 40
paient l'impôt société à 8% quand les
autres en payer 33 ou 34
c'est un débat récurrent mais très
légitime à mon avis qui ne fait qu
interpellée et interrogée régulièrement
comment ont-elles quelle approche avez
vous de cette situation je vis présent
écouter
nous nous vérifions lorsque nous sommes
auditeurs deux groupes français
l'impôt l'impôt la charge d'impôt
globale du groupe et donc on s'assure
que le calculer est correcte et que
hélas respecter la réglementation
française
dernière question concernant les lits
asb c'est bien de l'organisme et qui a
été évoqué c'est l'organisme qui définit
les règles normes comptables c'est bien
c'est une de l'organisme qui définit les
normes comptables et il a son siège dans
quel pays on dire on va dire à new york
mur et on ne rappellera pas non alors
c'est plus c'est plus compliqué que ça
l'iasb en fait qui définit les normes
insolite est quand même très influencé
par l'europe puisque l'union européenne
aa a été le premier je dirais la
première zone mondiale a demandé à ce
que ces normes s'impose la problématique
qu'il y assez qu'aujourd'hui on l'autre
l'autre jeu de normes je dirais qu il
reconnu au niveau mondial sur les normes
américaines et pendant plusieurs années
on a cherché à rapprocher de type non
pour qu'ils aient plus que des normes
généralement admise au niveau mondial or
il s'avère que ça aujourd'hui on
constate plutôt un échec puisque
américains continuent à suivre leurs
normes particulières tout en étant
membre de l'iasb et un lien grande
influence
ce qui est aboutie évidemment à à des
discussions assez sévère du fait que
nous avons allié sb à satan nombre de
personnes de nationalité américaine
alors que eux mêmes n'ont pas choisi ses
normes mais par exemple le trustee si je
puis dire pas la personne qui qui
surveille tout ça c'est quand même
monsieur michel prada a maintenant donc
on voit bien que l' influence européenne
assez forte par rapport à ce qu'elle
avait eu quel existé par le passé
mais vous avez raison c'est un point
extrêmement important parce que à partir
du moment où ces normes internationales
sans élaborer
elle s'applique forcément aux grands
groupes notamment aux grands groupes
français
y'avait pas avoir d impact très
important sur la vision l'image fidèle
des comptes de ces entreprises pour
aller dans le sens du rapporteur bon
vivre la question qui était posée
cela-dit différence entre les que très
grandes entreprises et les pme vous en
tant que praticien parce que c'est votre
question en train de praticiens vous
avez quand même un avis il ya une vraie
une vraie disparités où vous ne sentez
pas de disparité sur la fiscalité parce
que c'est une interrogation qu'on a
régulièrement dans ses auditions
est ce qu'il ya une vraie différence
pour les grandes entreprises
internationales par rapport à une pme
régionales parce que vous êtes quand
même un praticien alors c'est quand même
difficile de dire nous on sait sur
simplement de de savoir si la boe payer
ça je comprends bien c'est la loi mais
votre sentiment est ce que vous avez le
sentiment de d'une inégalité entre les
entreprises où vous avez le sentiment
quand même que une entreprise régionale
une pme a les mêmes chances dans son
évolution vis-à-vis de la fiscalité
tout le monde a la même chance et les
armes ne sont pas forcément les mêmes et
la taille non plus évidemment dans un
grand groupe international
nous avons des phillies et des
fiscalistes en interne qui gère la
fiscalité le jour dans une pme visant le
chef d'entreprise n'a pas ces moyens là
en général c'est par la matière de son
expert comptable mais les problématiques
sont quand même beaucoup moins de
complexes et a priori l'expert-comptable
il donne des bons conseils
exactement pour optimiser ce qui est
possible de faire dans le cadre de la
loi
non je pense pas qu'on puisse dire que
les 1/100 plus avantagés que les autres
les problématiques sont forcément
différentes parce que la taille et les
transactions
ne sont pas les mêmes questions qui y
président du caire est à vous remercier
de cette audition qui a été leur
emplettes et qui a éclairé les membres
de nos coutumes mission j'espère voilà
pour les travaux de la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur l'évasion
fiscale pour les revoir ou en savoir
plus notre site internet publicsenat.fr
très belle journée à tous